مساء الخير سهام ونادين طبعا انا اليوم
اتواجد في الجزء الشمالي من العاصمه بغداد
تحديدا في منطقه الاعظميه في قصر صدام او
المكان الذي كان قصرا للرئيس السابق صدام
حسين طبعا هذا المكان كان مهم جدا لدى
الرئيس السابق صدام حسين واني راح احدثكم
عن بعض عشرين عام من الحرب العراقيه
الامريكيه كيف اصبح هذا المكان هذا المكان
او هذا القصر او في السابق كان قصرا كان
تحفه من تحف صدام حسين طبعا
ضم تقريبا 600 غرفه وقاعه اجتماعات اضافه
الى 12 مسبحا وبحيره لصيد الاسماك تبلغ
مساحته 3000
طبعا هذا المكان تعرض للقصف الامريكي منذ
انشاء القصر يعني منذ عام
1995 الى 2003 كان على مرات متفاوته يتعرض
للقصف الامريكي طبعا جعل صدام حسين في
نهايه التسعينيات مقره لاستقبال لكبار
ضيوفه وكبار الشخصيات الذين كانوا يزورون
صدام حسين وبعض 2003 لم تنتهي اهميه هذا
المكان السياسي لقد اصبح مقرا للجيش
الامريكي بعد 2003 فيما بعد اصبح مقرا
للجيش العراقي وفي بدايه
2018/2018 يعني هذا المكان اقر له ان يكون
مستشفى لمكافحه المخدرات وعلاج مدمني
المخدرات لكن في منتصف عام 2018
تحول هذا القصر الى منتجع سياحي على طراز
الف ليله وليله يعني يضم سلسله من طعم
ويضم مدينه مائيه ويضم ايضا غرفا على طراز
وغرار قصص الف ليله وليله هذا القصر طبعا
واحد من مئات القصور من 100 من 100 قصر
لصدام حسين بني من الحجر العراقي
والمرمر اللبناني والجرانيت الايطالي يعني
زينب زينب خلينا هيك يعني نعطيك بريك لانه
حكيتي لنا كل تاريخ هذا القصر اسم الله
عليك طيب زينب اليوم انت بالفتره الاخيره
شاهده على كل الممتلكات والاماكن المرتبطه
بحقبه صدام حسين من اليخت في البصره
واليوم انت في شمال العاصمه العراقيه
بغداد من هذا القصر الذي تحول الى مقصد
للمواطنين والسياح اذا اردنا مثلا انا
وانت ان نذهب الى هذا القصر اليوم حيث انت
ما هي الفعاليات التي سنفعلها اليوم
وخصوصا في اجواء رمضان يعني انت اليوم عم
تاخديني في جوله في بغداد شو بنعمل بهذا
القصر هلا
بدايه القصر مطل على نهر دجله هذا اكثر ما
يميزه يعني اضافه الى هذا فكره المنتجع
بعد 203 يعني اليوم احنا ما راح نشاهد
نهائيا اي ملامح للقصر كلها تقريبا اختفت
وتحولت الى غرف على طراز الف ليله وليله
اكيد راح تستمتعين
المشاهد اللي هي تاخذك لعالم الف ليله
وليله وروايات الف ليله وليله وقصصها
واضافه الى هذا طبعا فقرات المسحراتي
وفقرات الحكايات اللي تتواجد هنا بالمنتجع
يعني الجلسات الموجوده بالخيم الرمضانيه
طبعا
اضافه يعني للاشياء التي تحدثتها عن القصر
وبما انه اخدتينا لموضوع اليخوت وقصر بابل
قصر بابل وليخوض صدام حسين ابد ما سكن
بقصر بابل ولا استقل هذه اليهود لكن في
قصر الاعظميه لا كان لصدام حسين وجوده هنا
ولهذا كان القصد جدا مهم وهاي وحده من
الاسباب اللي جعلتها يتعرض للقصف الامريكي
لاكثر من مره احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر زينب
المشاط من بغداد مراسله مساء العربيه